it wasn't the 52 people who were killed
it wasn't the countless others who had
their lives changed forever because
their family members were taken from
them
it was the hundreds of people that night
who couldn't make it home from
nightclubs in christchurch because all
the
[Music]
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tagalongs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
where my clothes had holes in love
and my afro was picky to the 90s
moschino and versace
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing sharla i'm
about to go out before i go out i really
found
the need to make this video last night i
went to smarter jenna's house
to record the podcast with brother slim
and adam salad which you can find out
and it was a very very interesting
discussion got a bit heated
but it's worth watching it's going to be
out tomorrow in charlotte sorcery
profiled
the podcast of slim and adam and it's
going to be out on my channel as well
inshallah
um the reason i mentioned this because
when i was going to his house i came
across this video that was sent to me
and was going viral
of an australian comedian and this
comedian is
uh basically making uh jokes he's making
jokes about the 52 people
that were literally massacred right um
and his
name is on twitter isaac butterfield i
think that's what his name is yeah so
it's quite popular in australia
and in the morning i woke up you know
we're going to watch the video together
and then in the morning when i woke up i
saw a video of him
kind of explaining his side like you
know look i'm a comedian we make these
kind of jokes i made
about jokes about all kinds of stuff etc
the thing that we need to discuss here
is this the statements that he
said and if we think about it how it
connects with orientalism
yeah um and the whole white man's burden
you know of
trying to save the other you know and
we're going to talk about that as one
shot let's get straight into it let's
watch this video and i want you guys
reaction as well
and then we're going to dissect it and
go through it and analyze
inshallah let's get straight into the
video so this was the very video
australian extremists stormed this
building this mosque
this room where people were saying their
prayers and going about their business
and for me the saddest thing about that
it wasn't the 52 people who were killed
it wasn't the countless others who had
their lives changed forever because
their family members were taken from
them
it was the hundreds of people that night
who couldn't make it home from
nightclubs in christchurch because all
the cabbies were dead
that's the video that specific segment
now
i watch this video in the morning and
video in the morning what he's done is
he's talking about the cancelled culture
you know the council culture of everyone
just gets cancer etc look i'll be honest
with you
do i believe he should lose his job
because of that statement he made
not really do i believe what he said was
absolutely disgusting
and vile yes does the muslim population
the muslims as a whole or even if he was
talking about the jews or et cetera do
would they deserve an apology
yes so the thing here is this and
i really want you guys to send this
video to him because i really want him
to understand that because i was very
emotional i was
upset you know and where he's coming
from he's saying this is my job this is
how i earn money and
i'm just committed i don't mean what i
say and it's made that very clear he's
saying look i don't mean what i say
i've talked about the 911 i've joined
him joked about the holocaust
he claims i don't know he says that yeah
now
really if that was said about the jews
if we used to say you know what
six million jews died yeah and if you
made a joke about six million jews died
and you know what the global economy is
going to crash
because all those bankers are dead yeah
because some people say you know it is
actually anti-semitic to claim
that the jews are the bankers and they
control the world if someone wants to
make a joke like that
let's be real the and the the the the
israeli
like the israelis the lobby israeli
lobby would
it's absolutely demolished and it'd be
in chaos he wouldn't lose his job he
would
never ever be doing that now in his joke
i want to analyze his job because in his
job he's very
interesting because edward syed talks
about this
in his book about orientalism yeah and
he talks about his interview that he had
um and he's he's talking about that
when the oklahoma bombings happened in
america the news reporters and people
were coming and saying this looks like a
middle eastern explosion or you know
anything
what the hell does a middle eastern
explosion look like well did you see a
like a turban on the
floor and his beard what did you see
what does what do you mean by that
when the oklahoma bombings happened they
realized that it was not middle eastern
uh attack it was a actually um
it was actually a domestic uh terrorist
attack done by two
white males right two or three of them
that killed
how many people yeah so the problem is
this
that we still have this colonial master
syndrome
we have this understanding this way of
thinking
that it's still within us today because
what is he saying he's saying
i'm not sorry about this this this and
this
i'm more upset that club goes
yeah so club goes those who are going
clubbing those who are entertaining
themselves those are the ones you know
who are living that
you know um the the the 21st century
lifestyle
and they're slaves you know they're the
cab drivers you know what he's doing is
he's putting
these people who have died children men
women innocent people
who are dead he puts them into the
category of cab drivers the cab drivers
they serve us they serve us i'm more
sorry in the context of
you know these um club goals i'm not
gonna have any cab drivers to go back
home
you can see the deep subliminal message
now i'm not saying he did this
intentional intention i'm not
like a conspiracy the theorist okay but
the point is you can see
that the only thing they saw that he
didn't say oh we've lost 52 solicitors
52 accountants 52 uh doctors or 52
nurses
cab drivers club goers club goals are
suffering because
of um cab drivers are dead now
i just want to challenge his defense of
it's a joke it's not a joke
if your child yeah um i forgot your name
once again let me see what your name is
okay
isaac isaac i just want you to hear me
yeah and i want you guys to send this
video to him isaac
if this was your child imagine you had
two beautiful daughters maybe you do
maybe you have
children yeah imagine somebody came to
your house
shot them and made god protect them yeah
i know you don't believe in god but may
god protect them yeah
and we would love to send the quran to
you by the way if you want to gain
controversy would love for you to read
the quran
if at point blank range one was shot in
the head
and one was stabbed to death and your
wife was i don't know
raped or whatever and then killed
if as a comedian as a muslim comedian
unless i'm a muslim comedian
i came out and i made a joke
a joke it's a joke they know i'm a
comedian it's my profession i came out
and said you know what guys
you know um i don't know what the drugs
are making my jobs are quite dead to be
honest
if i was to make a joke about two
white i don't know white babies
and a woman who got raped or something
like yo your wife and your two kids
if i was to make any kind of joke please
tell me isaac
how would you feel knowing that you
witnessed
and you saw the death of your loved ones
your children your kids your innocent
souls
where allah says in the quran killing
one soul is as if you kill the whole of
humanity
that's how dear and precious a life is
how would you feel that i make a joke
when you're suffering and
grieving in pain and you are probably
going through psychological
trauma to bury your loved ones
isaac i just want you to tell me would
you say would you defend
my freedom of speech of the joke that i
make about your
the death the murder the massacre of
your two kids
and um your wife
would you see as a joke and on top of
that you've got a bunch of people
laughing imagine they're muslims and
they're like
would you say actually he's just a
comedian he's doing his job
or would you really feel frustrated we
would feel so upset and so hurt
that your loved ones are just a mere
joke
so isaac like i said before i'm not
going to the extremes of council culture
lose your job
let's put the pressure i could have make
that video like this put pressure on it
i'm telling you at least apologize and
at least understand
i would really appreciate for you to
reply to this message not to me
to this message how would you feel if i
made that joke about your loved ones
you wouldn't like it so why is it when
it's 52 innocent muslims
who have been shot dead because of an
attack that we dehumanize them to a
level that it's an absolute joke
amongst people are laughing and people
are
like would that would have that been
said if we was to make that joke
about a group of white people no it
would have not so i want to end on that
no i do not want to carry it any further
i do not want to
come here and call you names etc you
know what yes i was very upset
i was very angry yes
i'm just saying isaac please for god's
sake
just understand and have some emotional
intelligence
and your jokes does do not have to be at
a point or to a level
where you are making fun out of dead
people people have passed away
which is absolutely in our religion not
even allowed someone just passed away
his affairs with god
leave it at that brothers and sisters
thank you for watching until next time
assalamu alaikum tonight